REPORTING FROM CONG NANTUCKET, K
YOU.
JOINING US DR. FRANCES COLLINS.
GOOD MORNING, SIR.
WHAT DO WE NEED TO KNOW ABOUT
THE OMICRON VARIANT, IS IT MORE
CONTAGIOUS?
WILL IT LEAD TO SEVERE DISEASE?
YOUR THOUGHTS, SIR.
>> THOSE ARE THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS, TRACE.
A LOT OF US WANT ANSWERS AND I
THINK I'VE BEEN ON ZOOM CALLS
AND PHONE CALLS CONTINUOUSLY.
WE KNOW THIS IS A VARIANT THAT
HAS A LOT OF MUTATIONS, LIKE 50
OF THEM.
MORE THAN 30 IN THE SPIKE
PROTEIN, THE PART OF THE VIRUS
THAT ATTACHES TO YOUR HUMAN
CELLS THAT GET INFECTED.
THAT IS A NEW RECORD, MAKES YOU
WORRY IT IS SUFFICIENTLY
DIFFERENT VIRUS IS MAY NOT
RESPOND WELL TO PROTECTION OF
THE VACCINE, BUT WE DON'T KNOW
THAT.
SOUTH AFRICA AND THE SOUTH PART
OF AFRICA, THIS DOES SEEM TO BE
SPREADING RAPIDLY, THE NFRPS
WOULD BE IT IS CONTAGIOUS, WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT SEVERITY,
TRYING TO COLLECT THE DATA AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
>> I'M INTERESTED, SPIKED
PROTEIN TEND TO CONFUSE PEOPLE,
WHEN YOU SAY VARIOUS MUTATION,
WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY THAT?
>> SO REMEMBER THE PICTURE OF
THIS VIRUS, IT HAS SPIKES ON THE
SURFACE MADE UP OF PROTEIN, THE
PART OF THE VIRUS THAT FINDS
RECEPTOR ON YOUR CELL TO GET
INSIDE.
THERE IS A LOCK AND KEY THERE.
THIS ONE IS FAERNTLY ABLE TO DO
THAT, IT IS INFEBLTHFECTING
PEOPLE.
SHAPE OF PROT TEEN IS DIFFERENT
BECAUSE OF 30 PLUS MUTATIONS AND
LOOKS DIFFERENT.  IF YOU RAISED
IMMUNITY PREVIOUSLY, WILL THE
ANTIBODIES STICK TO THIS VERSION
OF THE SPIKE PROTEIN OR WILL IT
EVADE THAT PROTECTION?
NEED TO FIND OUT, THAT WILL TAKE
TWO OR THREE WEEKS TO FIGURE OUT
THE ANSWER AND THAT IS WHAT WE
WANT TO KNOW.
>> QUICKLY, WE KNOW YOU DON'T
KNOW MUCH ABOUT THE VARIANT,ING
WHEN YOU HAVE DOCTORS IN THE
SOUTH AFRICA REGION, ONE WHO
SPOTTED THIS VARIANT, HE SAID
SYMPTOMS TEND TO BE MILD, IT IS
TOO EARLY TO MAKE THAT
DECLARATION?
>> I CONTINUING IS TOO EARLY,
PEOPLE WITH MILD INFECTIONS, WE
NEED MORE DATA BEFORE WE CAN SAY
THIS IS NOT SEVERE VERSION OF
THE VIRUS.
SHOULD FIND OUT IN THE NEXT
COUPLE WEEKS.
>> Trace: THE PRESIDENT PUT A
TRAVEL BAN ON EIGHTH SOUTH
AFRICAN COUNTRIES, PUT THOSE ON
THE SCREEN.
VACCINATION RATES OF THOSE
COUNTRIES GO UP TO 27% IN
LASUTU, AND 3.2 IN MALAWI, WHICH
IS LOW.
DR. EMMANUEL SAID RESTRICTING
TRAVEL WILL SLOW, IT IS COMING,
NOT STOP IT FROM COMING, THE
FACT IT IS COME SUGGEST
INEVITABLE, THE ENVIRONMENT IT
COMES MAY NOT BE INEVITABLE, WE
CAN ALTER THE ENVIRONMENT AND IF
IT IS JUST A CASE OF TRYING TO
SLOW IT DOWN, DR. COLLIN, WHY
NOT PUT IN PLACE MORE TRAVEL
BANS?
PEOPLE IN SOUTH AFRICA,
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS FEEL THEY
ARE BEING SINGLED OUT AND FEEL
THIS IS DISCRIMINATORY AGAINST
THEM.
>> WELL, I THINK IT IS A
DIFFICULT DECISION, TRACE, THIS
IS JUST BEST ADVICE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS.
U.K. AND E.U. ARE DOING THE
SAME.
EVERYBODY WHO IS A FOREIGN
TRAVELLER COMING TO THE U.S. HAS
TO HAVE A TEST, THREE DAYS IN
ADVANCE IF YOU ARE VACCINATED,
ONE DAY IN ADVANCE IF YOU ARE
UNVACCINATED.
GIVEN THE CURRENT CIRCUMSTANCE,
THIS IS THE MOST SERIOUS VARIANT
WE HAVE SEEN IN SEVERAL MONTHS,
IT MADE SENSE AT LEAST FOR
TEMPORARY MEASURE, WE WILL NOT
SAY THIS IS FOR A LONG HAD TIME,
TO BLOCK TRAVEL FROM COUNTRIES
WHERE WE KNOW OMICRON IS
SPREADING.
>> Trace: WE TALKED ABOUT
VACCINATION RATES IN SOUTH
AFRICAN COUNTRIES.
I WANT TO PUT UP RATES FROM THIS
COUNTRY, DOCTOR.  59.1% FULLY
VACCINATED.
19.1% OF BOOSTERS.
THE QUESTION IS, WILL THE
VACCINES NEED TO BE MODIFIED FOR
OMICRON?
IF THEY DO NEED TO BE MODIFIED,
WHY WOULD PEOPLE GET THE BO
O
BOOSTER TOMORROW IF THEY MIGHT
NEED A NEW ONE IN TWO MONTHS?
>> TRACE, FOR AMERICANS
LISTENING, THIS IS ACTION YOU
CAN TAKE, IF YOU ARE NOT
VACCINATED YET OR HAVEN'T GOTTEN
A BOOSTER, IT IS CLEAR IN THE
PREVIOUS EXAMPLES OF VARIANTS,
THE VACCINE HAVE WORKED TO
PROVIDE PROTECTION AND BOOSTERS
PROVIDE STRONG PROTECTION
AGAINST DELTA.
WE EXPECT MOST LIKELY CURRENT
VACCINES WILL BE SUFFICIENT TO
PROVIDE PROTECTION AND
ESPECIALLY THE BOOSTERS WILL
GIVE THAT ADDITIONAL LAYER OF
PROTECTION, THERE IS SOMETHING
ABOUT THE BOOSTER THAT CAUSES
YOUR IMMUNE SYSTEM TO EXPAND
CAPACITY AGAINST DIFFERENT SPIKE
PROTEINS, EVEN ONES IT HASN'T
SEEN BEFORE.
PLEASE, AMERICANS, IF YOU ARE
WAITING, THIS IS A GREAT TIME TO
SIGN UP AND GET YOUR BOOSTER.
OMICRON IS ONE REASON TO DO
THIS.
IF WE NEED A NEW VACCINE, PFIZER
AND MODERNA ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF DESIGNING THAT, THAT WILL BE
AT LEAST THREE MONTHS, IF WE
HAVE TO DO IT.
WE HOPE WE DON'T HAVE TO DO
THAT.
>> Trace: FOR NOW, THE TIME
BEING, THE VACCINES ARE WORKING
JUST FINE.
THE FOUR STATES AND VACCINATION
RATES, THAT GIVES AN IDEA WHERE
WE'RE GOING.
>> Mitch: MICHIGAN, 54%, MAINE,
SAME THING, HIGH VACCINATION
RATE, HIGH NEW CASES, NEW YORK
28, 62, FLORIDA 61% VACCINATION
RATE, DOWN IN CASES.
ONLY A COUPLE MONTHS AGO, MEDIA
WAS GIVING FLORIDA A HARD TIME
SAYING DeSANTIS' POLICIES WERE
ALL WRONG.
STATESS LIKE FLORIDA HAVE NO
MANDATES AND ARE DOING QUITE
WELL SGLCHLTS I, IT COMES DOWN
WHO IS GETTING THE DISEASE OR
WHO IS IN THE HOSPITAL AND SICK
ENOUGH TO DIE.
GETTING A MILD CASES HAPPENS AS
BREAKTHREWS FROM THE VACCINATED
FOLKS, BOOSTERS PREVENT THAT.
TALK ABOUT WHO IS IN THE
HOSPITAL AND WHO IS DYING, THOSE
ARE UNVACCINATED PEOPLE AND
THERE ARE LOTS OF THOSE.
IF THERE IS A LESSON HERE, COME
ON, AMERICA, WE HAVE MISSED
CHANCE TO BE HIGHER LEVEL OF
VACCINATION THAT WOULD PUT US IN
STRONGER POSITION.
MISINFORMATION WE HAVE HEARD, WE
HAVE NOT DONE WHAT WE SHOULD
HAVE TO PROTECT OURSELVES.
IF OMICRON IS ONE MORE WAKE-UP
CALL, AMERICA, WAKE UP.
THE VACCINES ARE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE AND PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
USING THEM FOR A YEAR, $200
MILLION PEOPLE PLUS HAVE GOTTEN
INJECTED, THIS IS SOMETHING YOU
WANT FOR YOUR COMMUNITY.
>> Trace: YOU TALK ABOUT
ANTIVIRAL PILLS MERCK AND
PFIZER, SOME SAY THESE PILLS ARE
GAME-CHANGERS.
WE ARE TOLD THEY ARE EFFECTIVE,
ARE YOU AFRAID IT WILL LESSEN
PEOPLE'S NEED OR HURRY TO GET
THE VACCINE?
>> IT DOES WORRY ME, TRACE, IT
WOULD NOT BE A RATIONALE
CONCLUSION, THESE ARE PILLS YOU
TAKE IF YOU ARE SHOWN TO BE
INFECTED.
DO YOU WANT TO WEAR YOUR ST
BELT OR COUNT ON THE MEMORY
ROOM?
I THINK THE SEAT BELT IS A
BETTER DEAL.
VACCINES ARE YOUR SEATS BELT,
USE THEM.
IF YOU GET SICK, IT WILL BE
GREAT TO HAVE ANTIVIRALS, I AM
TICKLES TO SEE THEM EMERGING.
THE MERC DRUG AND THE PFIZER
DRUG ARE COMING UP.
PREVENTION IS BETTER THAN
TREATMENT.
>> Trace: THANK YO